uh I have to ask this question
if one of those athletes let's say
Gordon Ryan
I was the dictator of the world and this
would entertain me so I force you and
Gordon to do this uh to fight uh a bear
or a lion Gordon has to uh how would you
coach him to do it
uh to have any chance of winning
he goes in empty hand empty-handed you
can choose Stadium or
um cage
Gordon Ryan empty-handed versus a lion
you get to choose lion versus bear it's
up to you okay my advice would be very
simple yeah I would say Gordon you're
[ __ ]
you're going to die badly
choose the lion because it will strangle
you to death rather than pin you down
and Maul you to death
didn't we just talk about audacious
goals
with Nicholas this is not a questionable
what day she's called this is a question
of minimizing pain so you coach your
athletes to quit before the battle has
been fought 100 yeah
you don't think there's a technique
first of all intelligence so technically
you gotta do a heel hook no no well
first of all maybe you kind of do a
double A he's got four [ __ ] legs okay
what if Gordon gets any starting
position he wants oh yeah that's gonna
be really useful
on a thousand pound beer yeah
[Music]
shaken off he'll get torn off with what
like the reaches back he's got four six
inches it's hard to oh you can't get I
wonder what is the reach what if he
touches he's got if it's not a flexible
bear so you think there's no control
what about like a low like a uh some
kind of controlling position from yeah
like you said
nothing this discussion is so insane I
didn't even know where to begin
criticism I don't think you're
open-minded we could we could turn this
down and forget about Gordon fighting a
a lion or a bear that's that's
completely impossible an adult male
chimp will destroy Gordon it's not even
a gorilla
is more than enough to kill any human on
the planet including Gordon Ryan so
Gordon Ryan fighting a chimp a good
sized no a thousand times how many times
does he win he loses a thousand times
it's not even competitive it's not even
remotely compared do you think he will
disagree
no
do you think anyone will disagree anyone
yeah [ __ ]